come close I've got a secret for you
closer closer closer okay ready
fifty-five percent of the world's
population lives in cities by 2050
that'll be two thirds of the world's
population so what does that mean can we
accommodate this trend should we what
are the pros and cons of urban density
and how bad can it get this is what F
and here's what would happen if everyone
on earth lived in one city today the
greatest population density ever
recorded was in Hong Kong's kowloon
walled city before forced evictions took
place in the early 1990s there were
33,000 people sharing this space which
is about the same area as street
football fields and that's the
equivalent of 1.2 million people per
square kilometre you can understand why
this walled city had to go but even if
that's an extreme example our world is
home to some pretty dense cities vanilla
is a city with roughly 43 thousand
people per square kilometre while the
population of Manhattan is about
twenty-six thousand per square kilometer
and while they're not the ideal
circumstances for claustrophobics most
people can make it work but how about a
city that houses the world's total
population could that work
it could but comfort would vary
depending on the density let's start
with a fun city
that has a pretty low population density
New Orleans is roughly 784 people per
square kilometer if you were to scale
New Orleans
to accommodate everyone in the world
you'd get a city the size of the
continental United States but if you
were to do the same thing to a high
population density city like Manila
which as we said has a population
density of 43,000 then everyone in the
world would have to fit into a city the
size of the country of Uruguay it's hard
to speculate on what life would be like
if everyone in the world lived in a city
this size in some ways it might be more
sustainable we'd save money on huge
infrastructure projects like long
highways and bridges travel and
transport costs would go down since all
the materials we'd need would be going
to the same place and that might make
basic human necessities like food and
medicine more accessible not to mention
having everything from work to home to
the supermarket and the shopping mall
within walking distance or accessible by
public transit would reduce our
environmental impact in fact people in
cities use half as much energy as people
who don't because they live in smaller
spaces but when we think about urban
living today it's impossible to ignore
the cost of rent with space at such a
premium how much would it cost to live
comfortably and what kind of quality of
life could low earners expect in Hong
Kong for example an incredibly dense
City with the most expensive housing
market in the world a 40 square metre
apartment costs about 700,000 dollars in
some places that kind of money could buy
you a castle but with the world crammed
into one city your living quarters might
look more like this the kind of geo city
we're envisioning raises a lot of social
questions people tend to move to cities
for better opportunities but would there
be enough to go around with the high
concentration of wealth inequality
that's often overlooked in today's world
read more crime
or even revolution with there still be
Wars or would our proximity to one
another help us understand each other a
little better and realize that we're not
so different after all a truly global
city is hard to imagine because distance
and diverse perspectives have bred
different approaches to urban planning
is there a one-size-fits-all approach to
cities how can we make herbal life
sustainable and accommodating to all
luckily the world will never live in
just one city but these are questions we
need to start taking seriously because
urban density is on the rise and like it
or not we're just gonna have to get more
comfortable with each other do you know
someone who's claustrophobic show them
this video and stay tuned for more what
if
[Music]